we asked you to vote for the 2017 movie
she wanted us to make an honest trailer
for here's your number four pick you
guys are weird
[Music]
from the mind behind Brooke Wien for a
dream Black Swan and Noah comes a
gruesome paranoid Bible allegory which
is kind of what you should expect by now
from the mind behind requiem for a green
Black Swan and Noah mother experienced a
gripping tale about something where this
mother and this guy have some
increasingly bad houseguests leave me
alone you're an arrogant stuff happens
then slowly but surely everything goes
cuckoo-bananas not so great
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on stop making me feel
dumb movie you're the dumb one stroke
your Chin's for what's either a
retelling of the Bible from nature's
perspective and allegory about global
warming a meditation on the creative
process a critique of traditional gender
roles or a story about how hard it is to
date a famous person in this film that
refuses to answer basic questions about
plot or character but does tell you what
Extreme Home Makeover would look like if
it were directed by Satan move that wise
[Music]
move it back move it back witness
gruesome imagery that will disturb you
to your very core where a baby be eaten
alive is nothing compared to a close-up
of Javier Bardem smiling Kristen Wiig
acting serious be inspirational and
unprepared public speaking or just say
something see this is my actual worst
nightmare follow Jennifer Lawrence's
giant face around for half the runtime
as she takes on a non-stop barrage of
household chores generally walks around
[Applause]
and stares at the wall but if that
sounds boring wait until you hear what
her husband is going through he's a poet
with writer's block whoa man this movie
sounds like it was written by a guy with
a lot of scarves oh right so dive into
the esoteric film that audiences either
loved hated or releated in this film
that looks and sounds beautiful avoids
easy categorization and really makes the
audience thing you know fits everyone in
a different way it is not him but
sometimes feels like the whole thing was
dashed out over a long weekend because
it was starring Hunger Games literally
Catching Fire
No Country for Old Testaments dread
Flanders caddy woman
a mcpoyle brother what it feels like to
host your in-laws and such things not
braced yet could you get down from there
that sinks not raced down get down from
there please get down from there please
we get it already don't sit in the sink
cheese you're not my real mom Big
Momma's House three if there's one thing
you can count on in the movie it's that
a writer working in isolation will
always go insane I asked of X a question
in a dead language and she opened the
gates to hell
banana crumpets somebody once told me
that I was Mike Wazowski I'm just a poor
boy from a poor family eating Tide Pods
doesn't make you cool